John Legend he became a member of
Hollywood royalty when he joined the II
got club you know John is just the 15th
person to win an Emmy Grammy Oscar and a
Tony and now he has the opportunity to
add another award well that's if he can
pull off a win as a new coach on the
voice that's here John's been a guest
and a mentor on the voice before and
says he hopes the world is ready for
team JL the announcement caps off a huge
week for this legend who's also
celebrating five years of wedded bliss
with white Chrissy Teigen tomorrow it's
gonna be mellow we've had a crazy week
we're gonna do something nice but it's
gonna be mellow we said to each other
how grateful we were for our lives the
other day we caught up with legend and a
host of famous father's at the good+
foundation event in New York last night
supporting families and dads living in
poverty fellow Emmy winner Tiffany
Haddish told us she's getting ready for
Monday's primetime awards but don't
expect to see her in that famous white
dress Colin Jost and Michael che co-host
for the first time they're also nominees
just like their SNL castmate Leslie
Jones who says there's no telling what
the guys have planned are you excited to
kick this carpet I was with Colin and
Michael earlier today as they rolled out
the gold carpet for the big event will
there be one person who on Tuesday is
like I hate them yes my ex-girlfriend
X Gerald and if she's watching this
right now
a cap now I'm gonna okay I'm kid I don't
get great she's great
[Applause]
you